jon-fen [ __ ] I am too I love horror
movies and one of the best horror movies
has come out a recent movie in years
this is a delivery failed is Annabelle
yes everybody loved it everybody under
Hannah Bell hundred and eighty percent
of Rotten Tomatoes yeah everyone was
like thank God the conjuring gave us
something good people were a little bit
like skeptical at first
yeah those worries were put to rest
right when that movie came out and
holding and now we got the highly
anticipated sequel Annabelle - so
excited
ah no girl
is it other hard Oh nipple chill there
are hard I'm gonna see the nipple chill
a long time well done well it's back
shot its back dude fulfills our bed it's
gonna make money
Billy totally is a great teaser it's
great to integrate teaser in fact I kind
of don't want to see a trailer now I
mean if you get a good teaser out if it
gets scary trailer out people will tune
in they don't care what review saying
[ __ ] people will check it out I know
they got the director of lights out to
do this one yeah which is cool cuz
lights out was an awesome film I feel
like it's a great transitions
considering James Vaughn did the
conjuring which introduced Annabelle and
that franchise and now animals been spun
off and heat for James want produce
lights out so we got it Rick from there
to do this cool connection cool
correlation does get me excited to see
this movie I'll admit I've seen the
conjuring wanted to did not see the
first Annabelle moon I you I really
didn't have an interest in it even
though I remember the first trailer kind
of scaring me yeah it looked creepy upon
initial on ischl impression but oh yeah
didn't hear anything then and I remember
in the conjuring the Annabelle set up
was really scary of that doll 20 ham
balls become like the biggest star it's
like their Wolverine yeah it's weird
cause like you know the concept of
Annabelle still seems to freak people
out and the doll design they did for
this movie because the original one is
just a Raggedy Ann but this is like a
[ __ ] up looking you know china doll or
something it's weird how it seems like
so many people like Annabelle herself
and just not that movie so is this like
one that kind of goes into the past a
little bit more this is this looks much
looks like it's a I feel like is it a
bigger cheese yo yeah it looks like it I
mean I feel like this is an origin I got
this is the little girl with Annabelle
eventually her soul will trans transfer
into that doll yeah because in the plot
description they say a doll maker and
his wife so I'm assuming she's the wife
of the doll maker yeah and they make
that doll origin story
oh so the little girl she is
little girl is animal this is exciting
to me I mean like it seems like we're
finally coming back to a nice time for
studio horror films you know they have a
different aesthetic they hit different
beats and all that I don't think studio
horror films or my favorite ones but you
know it's like as we saw with the
conjuring it's like you can kind of have
all the sweeping tones you know you can
have some really scary stuff but you can
also have a great romance and you can
have you know an interesting period like
they're investing in period piece horror
movies and so that's exciting to me
especially with this a lot of times two
horror movies seem to go out of their
way to get like good actors yeah Miranda
Otto's great like I I always enjoy
seeing her on screen and I'm happy to
see her in something like this - I hope
she can really lead this movie you know
I'm glad they're dropping money on
period piece horror with the first
Annabelle a lot of people felt that it
was rather cliche something tells me
that this director especially if James
James Wan is active in the producing
part of this film I feel like they might
be able to come up with something much
more original cuz they clearly still
have faith in it I mean at first
Annabelle made money it made my laundry
films continue to make money cinematic
universe or something around us which is
cool and I hope this works I mean as
much as they have like an effective
teaser trailer and and those are my
favorite kind of teaser shutters they
just give you a scene pretty much what I
love just ending on the look of horror
in somebody's face instead of what
they're looking at like I that's always
the kind of epitome of horror to me is
like it doesn't matter what it is or
even if you can see it it's just like
she sells that look of terror and I'm
like yeah looks [ __ ] scary that's a
clever marketing to somebody does make
you go I want to see what the [ __ ] she's
looking at yeah good job marketing team
there I think David Sandberg is a very
capable director especially you know
what we've seen of his with lights out
and all that like I think he's got the
chops for this
I heard the funny thing is I heard that
the best seen in the original animal
there's one scene directed by James Wan
and I've heard that's the best scene in
really girls I think would be a cool
like Annabelle 3 mm-hmm is if it was
about like the doll up haunting the
Warrens
yeah if they kind of expanded that like
if they just said unicode you're afraid
three and it was about the warden Ross
yeah that sounds like CrossFit is like
oh we're making Annabelle three movie
but it's about the war just make a fully
fictional story where she breaks out
that case it's first yeah yeah that
would take it into it altogether
stranger territory you know and really
get into the fictional yeah head of
being beholden to at least you know true
accounts of things well it allowed them
to take the Warrens into something much
more fictional yeah because I know the
conjuring tries to honor historical
accuracy for a good part yeah it's not
like 100% but they I mean the conjuring
try to see her tell the ghost story yeah
yeah not the skeptical store but they
still like to take actual elements where
it seems like Annabelle is very much
like it's some fun fictional right yeah
this is a horror movie so it'd be kind
of cool to see like then just take the
warrants and put them and it's something
completely fictitious where they don't
have to say based on true events or
something you know well
Annabelle to Delta is coming out next
year 2017 in May May was the month the
spider-man movies usually get released I
hope that this is just as good as
spider-man 3 night if you're new to the
channel subscribe today become a reject
and you know watch some videos and
jockeys from by yourself oh yeah
facebook.com slash Blum House is where I
work the rest of the time reasons to
Jerry on Twitter and Instagram real
rejects everywhere else check us out on
Facebook Twitter all that stuff let's
give a shout to Luis Guzman Louisa's Mon
Luis Guzman he tends to be a little
early to our videos many comments I
appreciate that Luis Luis is usually the
name of Mexican people
I like Mexicans Luis Guzman isn't he a
good character actor and I really hope
that it's him it's not him then it's him
and he's a fan of this channel so that
we can get him into one of our sketches
I really doubt it John I mean I doubt it
too
I don't think people like us know really
people don't seem to like this I feel
like a lot of people don't like us I
feel like our subscribers don't like us
actually Louise doesn't like us he's
early though he's early to a lot of our
video isn't really any comments a lot I
really appreciate it but I don't feel
that people
actually like us unless they actually
give us stuff so at least I would like
stuff to thrive appreciate if you're
Mexican
I don't know or Giottos if you can mail
us in a ricotta yeah
bean and cheese burrito um tortilla
chips